[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we're up here in Mount big
one must your way up how far up are we
away from the Salado sir I know exactly
how many meters above the sea level
around 1,000 I would say maybe even more
but how many mark let's say kilometers
numbers from sorry I'm around 20 no but
this is true war trail so this is a
shortcut if you go around it's it's
longer it's longer and then it says
mount Egmont mark here so they built a
masjid out over here yeah it says here
basically that our soldiers they were
fighting here for the whole war
basically three years this is what while
the the extremists what do you call it
chutney extremists exactly right
extremists that that's kind of like the
the call it you you the insane you know
today we have a lot of Islamophobia in
people you know on this part of the
world they don't know these were kind of
like the modern-day Crusaders who are
trying to eliminate all the Muslims we
decided you know I'm starting saying
we're like the only Muslims left here in
Europe so maybe there was that's one of
the backgrounds of the whole war they
say that we were supposed to be removed
from Bosnia so what of the efforts that
happened in college were criminals so
the people who are fighting against this
aggression of them killing innocent men
women and children these soldiers they
build the mosque up here yeah
basically they were spending here a lot
of time and you can see around there's
nothing between no buildings no houses
so the only remaining structure that
here now is Masjid so basically soldiers
says they had Jamaat daily her Masjid it
was reasonable and logical thing to
build them estrogen and to bring some
more safety and peace in in the in their
life that's over here
[Music]
is still living it's not just a
monumental hamdullah also there still is
monster still if they get put all the
way up here yep I can't say enough talk
about the benefits of the mountain also
we go to the athletic part of it so it's
really as you see the scenery is amazing
and when you come inside it's really
really different messages you cannot
find missed it like this many places so
this is a mosque here yeah all the way
you can see all the regulations
everything here so that means that this
Masjid is officially part of the
community of Muslims just as please
close the door because there's a lot of
animal strong this is you know as
Muslims we pray five times a day giving
thanks to the creator of all this
creator of us this trees the birds or
seven seas and we stop and we give
thanks
so before we pray we give we take the
evolution and this is the place where
the water is and then you you wash up
you have bottles of water there because
during the winter it's so cold here you
cannot if you open the water in the
pipes or the pipes so freezing cracks so
after we prepare for prayer and we go
pray and we say glory be to the one the
Most High who's not a man who's not a
woman who has no children who has no
beginning no and created the whole
universe and everything in it unique
like no other truly self-sufficient and
Arabic Allah and the language Jesus
spoke aloha and off
this is what people call me congregate
into the mosque I even go as you can see
when you walk into a muscular mosque you
don't see any statues you don't see any
idols it's just four walls carpeting and
then you pray everything and the wood is
the one that we saw outside because the
army was here there was no supplies no
construction companies no materials so
everything's built from what and this
message you can feel it through the cold
yeah even during the summer it's disco
because the natural isolation is so so
good and efficient new new interns all
right we're gonna go ahead and pray